appelle maintenant lydia guirous
guillaume pelletier damien abad
julien aubert daniel fasquelle
vice-président porte-parole membres de
notre mouvement et surtout des fers de
lance que vous voyez sur les dans les
médias et qui défendent notre vision de
la france et notre vision de l'europe
alors le temps passant je deviens de
plus en plus inquisiteur et je force mon
tempérament pour dire que je vais vous
poser des questions et que vous avez
trois minutes pour répondre je peux pas
vous couper le micro mais la salle vous
regardera avec un intérêt très très
particulier donc la première question
que je voudrais poser c'est à guillaume
guillaume j'aimerais que tu me parle de
quelque chose dont tu parles si bien
c'est le patriotisme économique et
commerciale et qui est une des bases
quand même de la défense de de l'europe
et de la vision connard nous les
républicains d'europe
guillaume pelletier merci jean quelques
mots très rapides notre génération est
évidemment européenne elle est née avec
l'europe
et pourtant les élites qui nous
gouvernent depuis très longtemps nous au
progressivement interdit de penser
l'europe avec nos mots comme bruno
retailleau l'a dit avec beaucoup de
vérités à l'instant on nous a refusé un
projet de civilisation
on nous a interdit d'être fiers de notre
identité de nos racines
judéo-chrétiennes
on nous a promis une europe de la
puissance de la croissance de la
réussite économique et aujourd'hui
l'europe est devenue un océan sans
aucune protection et sans aucune
frontière les mots d'identité les mots
de protection les mots de patriotisme
les mots de frontières ne sont pas des
gros mots ce sont des mots
indispensables aux peuples et entre
l'europe sans les peuples proposé par
emmanuel macron
entre la france sans l'europe proposé
par madame le pen nous nous incarnons
avec laurent wauquiez une troisième voie
l'europe de la protection l'europe des
frontières commerciales l'europe du
patriotisme économique
regardons ce qui se passe dans le monde
les chinois se protègent les russes se
protègent les américains se protègent
les sud américains se protège et
l'europe dictée soumise à la
mondialisation refuse de protéger
eh bien nous nous proposons une europe
de la protection une europe des
frontières une robe qui refusent la
fatalité de la mondialisation et qui
respecte notre identité nos agriculteurs
nos ouvriers nos employés nos
fonctionnaires une europe qui respecte
l'identité des peuples et la
souveraineté des peuples
bravo bravo pour le timing et bravo pour
le message lydia lydia guirous ce la
genèse on a peut-être un peu perdu
l'habitude dans notre mouvement de
parler à la genèse et de lui proposer un
projet d'avenir
est ce que l'europe est un projet
d'avenir pour la jeunesse
merci genre oui oui l'europe est en
projet d'avenir pour la jeunesse et pour
ça nous devons lui faire une proposition
moi je vais vous parler de l'une des
plus belles années de ma vie qui était
l'erasmus j'ai eu la chance de faire
partie de ces jeunes qui ont pu
bénéficier du programme erasmus pourtant
j'étais une étudiante boursière et
aujourd'hui vous avez seulement 5% des
élèves qui peuvent avoir accès à erasmus
est allé étudier pendant une année dans
un pays de l'union européenne
alors qu'est ce qu'on a découvert
pendant cette année nous étions tous
fiers d'être français d'être italien
d'être polonais d'être allemand mais
nous avons aussi surtout découvert cette
conscience européenne
nous avons découvert que nous avions des
valeurs communes et quelles étaient ses
valeurs et ses valeurs c'est d'abord
l'égalité hommes femmes l'égalité hommes
femmes parce que en europe les femmes ne
se cache pas en europe les femmes nora
ce pas les murs l'europe c'est un peu le
far l'europe c'est le continent de la
liberté des femmes c'est là qu'est né le
féminisme c'est là qu'est née
l'émancipation des femmes et à un moment
où tous les pays connaissent la gangrène
islamiste où tous les pays subissent le
terrorisme islamiste
il faut que l'europe reste ce continent
de la liberté des femmes et à la veille
de l'entrée de simone veil au panthéon
je voudrais vous dire que son héritage
nous oblige nous français et nous
européens nous devons être d'une
certaine manière à la hauteur de cet
héritage et faire en sorte que l'europe
reste ce continent de liberté des femmes
car car il est sans cesse attaqué et je
pense qu'aucun d'entre vous ne peut ne
peut dire que que lorsque vous vous
promenez dans la rue il n'y a pas d
atteinte grave à la liberté des femmes
et et on peut que le déplorer mais au
delà des valeurs c'est aussi une
histoire commune c'est cette histoire
qui permet à l'europe de rayonner dans
le monde alors il ya d'abord les
conquérants c'est ces hommes qui sont
partis qui ont traversé les océans pour
découvrir le monde
il ya les résistants il ya également ces
philosophes ses auteurs ces artistes qui
ont fait rayonner l'esprit européen à
travers le monde et nous devons en être
fiers
mais les républicains ont le devoir de
proposer à l'ensemble d'une génération
d'accéder à à l'erasmus parce que ce
n'est pas uniquement les premiers de
cordée les enfants des grandes écoles
les enfants de la bourgeoisie qui
peuvent accéder à erasmus et il est vrai
que j'étais une exception - élèves
boursière à être dans ce programme
erasmus hausse
[Applaudissements]
or les républicains vont porter cette
proposition d'ouvrir leurs astuces aux
collégiens aux lycéens et également aux
apprentis dans une forme de
compagnonnage européen vous bravo c'est
en fait à travers erasmus c'est aussi
une forme de réarmement culturel que
nous devons apporter à la jeune
génération
parce qu'elle va avoir des défis qui
sont je pense ce comme ceux qu'ont pu
rencontrer nos aînés l'islamisme encore
une fois gangrène beaucoup de sociétés
européennes et il faut ce réarmement
culturel qui passera par la fierté
d'être européen et la fierté de défendre
les valeurs que nous avons en commun
merci les gars alors j'ai vu julien tout
à l'heure réagir très positivement à une
partie de discours quand on parler de
souveraineté
voilà et est ce que la souveraineté
nationale cher julien est compatible
avec la souveraineté européenne
vaste sujet c'est un sujet du bac
bon je voudrais remercier laurent
wauquiez nous donnait là évidemment la
possibilité d'exprimer notre diversité
enfin avec jean signe la même tribune
aujourd'hui
alors oui chers compagnons mes chers
amis le mot souveraineté ne doit pas
nous faire peur
la souveraineté c'est l'indépendance et
si nous sommes tous attachés à l'europe
l'europe comme projet de civilisation
c'est à dire que la turquie n'y a pas sa
place et que de mon point de vue un jour
il faudra discuter avec la russie cette
europe
elle ne peut pas se faire sans les
nations et en tant que parlementaire
nationale ce que je défends c'est le
peuple français ce sont les intérêts du
peuple français ce sont vos intérêts et
comme disait malraux en 1958
nul ne peut refaire la france sans les
français et la république le rappel
autrefois exilé le rappelle je veux
redevenir la france et notre projet doit
être de concilier cette inspiration
d'amour de notre nation avec le projet
européen et je pense aujourd'hui à
charles pasqua et hier laurent était sur
sa tombe
un gaulliste convaincu convaincu que la
seule europe possible était une europe
des nations et je vais vous dire ce que
les citoyens ne supporte plus c'est
qu'on leur impose des choses et qu'ils
ne puissent jamais revenir sur des
décisions c'est ça qui tue la démocratie
quand je vois sur les négociations
commerciales qu'on m'explique que le
parlement français ne sera plus
consultés quand je vois monsieur
moscovici expliqué que si le parlement
français a voté contre le traité sur le
ceta et bien le traiter s'appliquerait
quand même je me dis que nous avons un
problème dans la construction
démocratique de l'union européenne je me
dis que le parlement français ne peut
pas appliquer la souveraineté qui a reçu
du peuple et que nous devons trouver un
équilibre parce que nous devons prendre
des engagements et ses engagements et je
les donne pour l'avim des républicains
de la même manière que nous n'osons pas
laisser à monsieur macro le monopole de
l'europe
nous ne devons pas laisser à madame le
pen le monopole de la nation et nous
devons clairement affiché que nous
refusons le fédéralisme politique comme
objectifs de l'union
parce que l'europe disparaîtra si les
nations qui la composent disparaissent
parce que ce qui marche en europe c'est
la coopération d'état nation airbus
l'erasmus ce sont des projets qui ont
été développés par des coopérations
inter étatiques
laissons faire la flexibilité et d bruxe
élisons le plus possible les mécanismes
et enfin si nous ne sommes pas capables
d'arriver à une solution au niveau
européen
récupérons la maîtrise de notre destin
que
même nicolas sarkozy l'avait d'ailleurs
esquissé en 2007 en 2012 pardon sur
l'espace schengen nous devons nous
défendre parce que autour de nous autour
de nous l'europe est en crise en italie
en allemagne en grande-bretagne ne
faisons pas les autruches
nous devons récupérer la maîtrise de
notre destin parce que c'est une france
forte qui permettra de construire une
europe forte
ce qui suppose d'extirper de son adn les
gènes de la libre concurrence pure et
parfaite qui nous empêche d'avoir des
géants industriels et des géants
français industriels parce que nous le
devons au peuple français et parce que
les républicains doivent défendre la
république aux ogm
c'était le plus inquiétant pour toi
encore plus que pour moi c'est que je
suis d'accord avec toi je vous demande
chers amis d'accueillir brice hortefeux
formidable mise de l'intérieur de
nicolas sarkozy et je lui demande de
nous rejoindre la tribune damien tout à
l'heure marc-philippe évoquée il disait
je suis centriste et républicains et
bien est-ce qu'on peut être est ce qu'il
ya une droite européenne et est ce que
cette droite européenne au niveau
européen comme au niveau national porte
un projet cohérent
c'est la question que je te pose qui est
pas simple à répondre en trois minutes
merci jean bonjour à toutes et à tous eh
oui l'enjeu pour nous dans ces élections
européennes s'est il est il et il est
effectivement celui ci de démontrer
d'abord que notre famille politique la
droite c'est elle qui a construit
l'europe que nous aimions qui était
l'europe effectivement de la
construction de la paix et de la liberté
l'europe de schumann et de monnaies
l'europe du général de gaulle l'europe
aussi de jacques chirac et l'europe
également de nicolas sarkozy ne
l'oublions jamais bien entendue
alors on a pas on n'a pas de leçon à
recevoir de personne
on n'a pas de brevet européen a demandé
à quiconque et encore moins au président
de la république qui est en train de
créer les conditions de l'europe de
l'impossible de l'europe de
l'impuissance et de l'europe de
l'inaction
jour après jour on le voit sur la crise
migrants on le voit sur les résultats
économiques et on le voit
malheureusement sur l'europe politique
est en panne alors sept à notre famille
politique et à elle seule de la porter
haut et fort comme nos pères fondateurs
l'ont fait c'est l'ambition de toute
notre génération bien entendu alors oui
bien sûr que l'europe est en crise et
bien sûr qu'il ya des crises en europe
et bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui l'europe a
dérivé sur une europe des normes que
nous ne voulons plus parce qu'elle s'est
éloigné notre propre ambition
ce que nous devons construire
aujourd'hui au delà de l'europe de la
paix de l'europe des libertés
c'est cette europe de la sécurité et
c'est cela l'enjeu l'europe de la
sécurité alimentaire comme l'a dit tout
à l'heure michel dantin avec un principe
simple nous sommes les défenseurs de la
politique agricole commune
parce que nous défendons les
agriculteurs et parce que nous défendons
celles et ceux qui créent de la richesse
et l'activité dans notre pays mais nous
sommes également le défenseur de
l'europe de la sécurité économique celle
comme l'a dit guillaume qui est celle la
défense du patriotisme économique
parce qu'on ne peut plus accepter que
des produits qui viennent de l'extérieur
de l'union européenne ne respecte pas
les mêmes normes sociales sanitaires et
environnementales que celle vous
demandons à nos propres producteurs ça
sera bien sûr aussi l'europe de la
sécurité climatique parce qu'on le sait
l'enjeu du réchauffement climatique est
important celle de la sécurité numérique
également et de toute sécurité dont nous
avons besoin et dont la première bien
entendu et celle de la question
migratoire qu'elle aveuglément que nous
ne pas comprendre ou de ne pas croire ou
nous faire croire que finalement la
question prioritaire pour nous ce ne
serait pas la résolution de la question
de la crise migratoire
parce que si
on tombe sur cette question c'est
l'europe entière qui s'effondrera alors
oui en matière de sécurité et en matière
d'immigration il n'y a pas de place pour
la politique du en même temps on veut
une politique du courage de la volonté
et des idées c'est cela que doit être
dans d'ambition également pour l'europe
et enfin pour pour conclure je voudrais
simplement vous dire ceci effectivement
nous sommes à quelques heures de
l'entrée de simone veil au panthéon
elle disait que l'europe c'est le dessin
du 21e siècle et bien nous devons passer
ensemble sur le fait que pour retrouver
une ambition pour l'europe il faut
d'abord retrouver une ambition pour la
france
nous nous aimons cette france qui lutte
contre l'islamisme radical
cette france qui luttent contre
l'intolérance religieuse cette france
qui lutte contre les inégalités
cette france qui luttent contre toutes
celles et tous ceux qui veulent abîmé
notre culture notre identité et notre
république alors s'il ya un destin
européen pour nous les français c'est
celui de faire rayonner la france de
porter nos idées notre identité et notre
valeur et nos cultures en france mais
aussi en europe
merci monsieur le vice président si je
devais le résumé et comment peut-on
résumer toujours un homme je dirais que
daniel daniel fasquelle est un gaulliste
social et je voudrais lui poser une
question qui nous taraude tous et qui a
été évoquée déjà comment ça se fait que
avec tout ce que l'europe a apporté et
malgré ses imperfections et bien les
citoyens considèrent encore est de plus
en plus l'europe comme une machine
négative comment réconcilier les
citoyens avec l'europe
daniel lui avait coûté bonbon jours à
tous ouais d'abord vous
vous remercier pour votre soutien et
votre fidélité vous êtes là et vous dire
que un mot simplement en tant que
trésorier national moi je suis très fier
d'être aux côtés de laurent wauquiez est
avec vous êtes en train de redresser
financièrement notre parti on aura dans
deux ans rembourser 80 % notre dette si
ma croiser autant pour le pays la france
irait beaucoup mieux
ensuite moi je viens de l'autre bout de
la france je suis député du pas de
calais et je vois ce qui se passe chez
nos amis britanniques qui ont décidé du
break site et chaque jour voit là il
découvre que en réalité ça a été très
mauvaise décision
après le siège des institutions
européennes qui ont quitté la
grande-bretagne
maintenant ce sont les entreprises qui
quitte la bateau la grande-bretagne
airbus par exemple a annoncé qu'ils
allaient quitter le sol britannique
et en cas de brick site dur la grande
bretagne va perdre quasiment un million
d'emplois
si dire à quel point l'europe est
précieuse et avant de dire comme
certains qu'il faut sortir de l'europe
casser l'europe est cassée l'euro il
faut voir ce qui se passe chez nos
voisins britanniques et voir les
conséquences dramatiques que serait pour
la france fait que nous quittions
l'europe
et pourtant cette europe c'est la
question que tu poses et bien elle n'a
pas su créer un lien de confiance avec
nos concitoyens avec les citoyens
européens
alors comment changer les choses bien
tout simplement il faut transformer
l'europe une rock où tout part d'en haut
où tout est décidé dans des sphères
qu'on ne comprend pas il faut une europe
au contraire hutu parts d'en bas une
europe d'abord qui règle les problèmes
concrets des européens je vais vous
donner simplement un exemple j'étais
accueilli ce matin par nos amis
chasseurs de cpnt
j'ai des sachets chasseurs de gibier
d'eau chez moi sachez par exemple que
s'agissant de la chasse aux oies et bien
on interdit aux chasseurs français de
chasser les oies en février et puis
quelques semaines après on les gaz aux
pays bas parce que eh bien c'est juste
c'est soit sont trop nombreux aux
pays-bas et qu' ils causent des dégâts
importants sur les récoltes
est-ce que l'on peut accepter cette
europe alors on fait passer les messages
avec mes amis chasseurs depuis des
années ces messages ne sont pas entendus
cette europe là nous n'en voulons plus
cette europe elle doit régler les
problèmes concrets de
ces citoyens européens les agriculteurs
damien en parler est ce que vous trouvez
normal qu'on impose des normes aussi
importantes aux agriculteurs français
alors qu'en même temps et bien on a
baissé tout contrôle à nos frontières et
qu'on laisse entrer en europe des
produits agricoles qui ont été fabriqués
avec des normes qu'ils sont absolument
pas les mêmes
cette concurrence déloyale elle est
absolument insupportable il faut à tout
prix y mettre fin
il faut une europe qui règle les
problèmes concrets des européens
il faut aussi une europe qui ne crée pas
de problème nouveau la question des
travailleurs détachés est insupportable
la question des normes est ce qu'on a
besoin d'une directive sur le chocolat
est ce qu'on a besoin d'une directive
sur les confitures est ce qu'on a besoin
de rentrer dans ce luxe de détails
non il faut que l'europe soit moins
bureaucratique il faut moins de normes
européennes
il faut plus de liberté pour les
entreprises et pour les états et puis
enfin je dirais qu'il faut une europe
qui consultent les européens vous avez
vous devez pouvoir donner votre avis sur
les sujets qui vous concerne la question
des élargissements je sais que laurent y
tient beaucoup
est ce qu'il est normal que l'on décide
à bruxelles d'élargissement futur est ce
que c'est normal c'était dit ce matin
qu'on invite la turquie à des réunions à
bruxelles
alors qu'on nous a pas consultés non
demain pas un seul élargissement sans
que les français donné leur accord et
sans que les français aient donné leur
accord
c'est vrai aussi pour la politique
migratoire
vous avez vu ce conseil européen
lamentable cette unité de façade ce
conseil européen pour dire que en
réalité chaque état fera ce qu'il veut
nous ne voulons plus de cette europe là
il faut une europe qui protège vraiment
nos frontières et pour cela et européens
doivent être consultés il faut qu'à
bruxelles et à strasbourg on entend la
volonté des européens
et s'agissant de contrer contrôler les
flux migratoires
les européens sont clairs ils doivent
être entendus il faut protéger nos
frontières il faut éviter mettre fin
cette immigration massive dans les
fruits européens ne veulent plus en
conclusion je dirais que point consigner
les européens avec l'europe il faut une
europe qui soit au service des états
unis rock qui soit au service des
français
une europe qui soit enfin au service des
eaux
r à vos biens pour conclure l'ensemble
de cette table ronde
je demande à brice qu'un talent de
synthèse exceptionnelle de dire son
projet européen lui qui a été mise
d'intérieur de nicolas sarkozy et qui
aujourd'hui député européen on applaudit
brice bond à boersch cherchant d'abord
mille excuses parce que je suis arrivé
très en retard
ça confirme ce que je pensais menton
c'est beau mais c'est loin
j'ai déjà entendu ça quelque part mais
sur le trajet très court ça va de soi
entre nice et menton
j'écoutais la radio et notamment sur une
radio qui diffuse toutes les 30 minutes
la même idée et sur la radio sur cette
radio c'était conseil national des
républicains à menton ils se déchirent
ils se disputent ils sont pas d'accord
et ben moi je vais vous dire quelque
chose je suis arrivé en retard je n'ai
pas entendu ce qui a été dit avant mais
par principe je suis d'accord avec ce
qui a été dit bravo
et c'est le meilleur moyen c'est le
meilleur moyen pour que nous offrions
l'image de ce que doit être une
opposition unie crédible porteur
d'espoir incarnant l'alternance
parce que si l'unité n'est pas la
certitude du sud the sand est néanmoins
la condition alors j'imagine que depuis
ce matin tout a été dit donc je vais pas
rajouté beaucoup de choses tout était
dit par les uns et les autres
daniel est donc gaulliste et sociale je
croyais que c'était julien robert qui
était sociale et gaullisme enfin c'est
très bien ça pour qu'on est tous sur la
même ligne
et j'imagine aussi que tu en as chida
que nadine avec discrétion mais
certainement beaucoup de conviction ont
parlé et des questions migratoires
je vous le dis là aussi
à ma manière avec mes mots avec la même
forme de conviction c'est que le chaos
migratoires dans lequel nous vivons qui
a fait qu il y a trois ans un million
huit cent mille franchissement des
frontières européennes ont été
enregistrés aujourd'hui comme je lé
évoqué avec notre président laurent
wauquiez les toute l'équipe dirigeante
il y a deux trois jours aujourd'hui les
responsables allemands eux mêmes disent
que sur ces bleus millions qui s'est
rendu en allemagne les deux tiers
n'étaient pas des réfugiés politiques
que aujourd'hui ces mêmes autorités
allemandes constate avec désespoir que
85 % de ceux qui se sont installés ont
échoué leur intégration et vivent de la
redistribution sociale
ça c'est pas l'europe que nous voulons
c'est pas l'europe qu'avec est sous
l'autorité de nicolas sarkozy lorsque la
france présidait l'union européenne nous
avions proposé avec succès c'est
l'europe qui doit être capable de dire
oui mais qui doit pas qui doit être
capable aussi de dire non c'est à dire
linverse de l'europe d'emmanuel macro où
on dit tout à la fois et en même temps
oui et non de manière à ce que l'on n'y
comprennent rien la réalité simple c'est
que aujourd'hui ça ne peut plus
continuer nous ne pouvons plus continuer
à accueillir indéfiniment les quatre
cent mille clandestins qui vivent
illégalement sur notre territoire
les 400 milles qui sont arrivées cette
l'année dernière en 2017 sur notre
territoire nous n'en avons ni le besoin
ni la capacité et c'est pour cela que
pour bâtir cette europe
nous devons bien tous avoir conscience
que la solution ne peut pas être
exclusivement européenne
comme le dit la majorité qui nous
gouvernent aujourd'hui que la solution
ne peut pas être exclusivement
nationales comme le rassemblement
national ex front national pour ce qui
est poursuivi comme le front national le
disait la solution passe par une marche
sur les deux jambes à la fois la
nationale et l'européenne et c'est toute
l'ambition qui doit être la nôtre
autour de laurent wauquiez pour demain
gagner ce scrutin bravo merci brice
[Applaudissements]